Ready for a serious case of the heebie-jeebies?
Sony Pictures has released the first official
poster for its upcoming remake/reboot/sequel
The Grudge, and we sincerely hope that you're
not about to jump in the shower.
The one-sheet references an iconic scene from
the 2004 film that has literally never stopped
giving us the creeps.
In case you're not familiar, that flick itself
a remake of the 2002 Japanese film Ju-On:
The Grudge starred Sarah Michelle Gellar as
Karen Davis, an American exchange student
in Japan who moves into a house populated
by malevolent spirits.
These are no run-of-the-mill spooks, however;
they're an extra-virulent variety created
when one dies under extraordinarily emotional
circumstances, and as the flick's title implies,
they don't go away... ever.
In the scene in question, Karen is enjoying
a nice, hot shower, and is in the middle of
washing her hair when she suddenly appears
to grow an extra hand... from the back of
her head.
It's an incredibly unnerving jump scare, and
the fact that the new flick's producers chose
to invoke it for their movie's first poster
tells us something about the specific vein
of terror they're hoping to mine.
As the poster notes, Sam Raimi, who served
as a producer on the 2004 film and the first
of its two sequels, is back in that role for
this go-round.
He's got an interesting talent in the director's
chair: Nicolas Pesce who turned in low-key,
slow-burn, minor masterpieces with 2016's
Eyes of My Mother and 2018's Piercing.
According to Pesce, his film will more than
make good on this poster's promise to scare
the absolute hell out of you.
The director has explained that he views The
Grudge as, quote, "an anthology series...
[featuring] different characters, different
stories, different locations, different ghosts,"
and while he is taking care to stay true to
what came before, he promises that when it
comes to the level of pure terror he's going
for, audiences simply aren't ready.
Pesce told a crowd at New York Comic-Con:
"The movie's way more f----d up [than the
other films in the series].
Not that the wave of J-Horror in the early
2000s wasn't f----d up — but this is really
f----d up."
Pesce went on to explain that he rejects the
"reboot" label, as his Grudge takes place
in the same timeline as the 2004 movie, and
that he is in no way simply telling a different
version of the same story.
He explained:
"We're not rehashing [the first film].
We're finding the key elements that are just
how the grudge expresses itself.
So much of this movie is about the fact that
this can happen anywhere and that it happens
everywhere.
It can spread like wildfire.
Having certain touchstones was important.
Obviously with a franchise we don't want to
throw everything out.
There is certain stuff that is fun for the
fans to see again in a new context with a
new spin."
The director also let slip a few details about
the flick's plot in a conversation with Entertainment
Weekly.
It will focus on a police officer played by
Mandy's Andrea Riseborough who arrives in
a new town only to be handed a bizarre and
inexplicable case one which leads her to investigate
a mysterious house that, as Pesce describes
it, quote, "has been grudged."
The director explained:
"We follow her, as well as two other storylines,
that are all interacting with this 'grudged'
house in small town America.
Like the old films, it's a tapestry of three
different stories that interweave and all
take place at slightly different times, centered
around this one house that's at the center
of this case that this cop is working on."
That sounds really cool, but we're going to
need a bit more confirmation on the movie's
fright factor.
Let's check in with horror legend Lin Shaye,
who is also appearing in the film, and who
had a few choice words when asked about the
project in an interview with ComicBook.
Shaye dished:
"Wait until you see this.
It's the scariest movie I've ever been a part
of, not even maybe.
Not even maybe.
It's the scariest part I've ever had, bar
none...
I'm very excited about it.
The horror fans are going to go insane, that
I can promise."
Okay, that's all we needed, we're officially
on board.
In addition to Riseborough and Shaye, The
Grudge stars Betty Gilpin, John Cho, William
Sadler, and Demian Bichir.
The haunting flick will hit screens on January
3, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.